fue justo en el vídeo pasado donde
hablamos acerca de un ácido débil así
que ahora vamos a intentar un ejemplo
con una base débil digamos que tenemos
por aquí
pago de amoniaco lo voy a poner aquí
amoniaco es n ok
h 3 punto g no con 3 hidrógenos ok y
bueno este vamos a decir que está en un
vamos a ponerlo así en una solución
acuosa este está en una solución acuosa
justo por aquí y este de aquí va a ser
considerado en la base débil ya que va a
aceptar un hidrógeno del agua lo que
quiere decir que al agua lo va a dejar
solo con un hidróxido así que aumenta la
concentración de hidróxido o de h
entonces tenemos a este de aquí un poco
de amoniaco en nosotros una cosa y vamos
a agregarle agua entonces a éste le voy
a agregar ok h2o ok y bueno el agua está
en estado líquido déjame ponerlo si está
en estado líquido de lujo y entonces ya
que tenemos esto y bueno sabemos que es
una base débil entonces esta reacción no
va a ir
solamente en una dirección va a ir en
ambas direcciones
esta reacción va a ir en ambas
direcciones va para acá ok pero también
va a el otro lado ok justo por aquí ok y
entonces que nos va a dar y bueno debido
a que es una base débil podemos
identificar la definición de proust de
laurie ya que es de aquí va a ser una
sector de protones en lugar de un
donante así que en lugar de seguir
siendo amoniaco se va a convertir en
amonio y nos va a quedar
y déjeme ponerlo con este color ok nos
va a quedar nh4 n h
4 y ya está aceptando un nitrógeno del
agua por lo tanto éste va a quedar con
carga positiva ok el cual también va a
estar en a una solución acuosa ok y
bueno aquí tenemos una muñoz o un cateo
en amonio es decir date cuenta que lo
único que tenemos es un hidrógeno además
y bueno como va a obtener este hidrógeno
del agua entonces nos va a quedar
y déjame ponerlo con otro color nos va a
quedar aquí
+ 1 o h 1
h negativo esto es lo que quedó de mi
molécula del agua
ok también en am en una solución acuosa
recuerda que si dos veces de la
definición de proust el noble estar aquí
fue un aceptar de protones ya que tomó
un hidrógeno del agua lo cual lo hace
una base ahora si lo vemos desde la
definición de arrhenius también es una
base porque incrementa la concentración
de hidróxido de h en la solución que era
justo la definición de reunión como sea
de una manera no sé no se me ocurre
tomarnos número al azar
imagínate que tenemos cero a 0.20 punto
2 molar a ver qué sale con estos 0.2 ok
mola de de bueno de nuestra sustancia
que es nh3 ok y ahora lo que queremos
averiguar es cuánto vale el ph así que
déjame ponerlo cuando este otro color yo
lo que quiero saber es cuánto va a valer
nuestro p
de estos 0.2 moles por litro de nh3 ok
me fui a la wikipedia de una pequeña
tabla en donde puedes encontrar casi
para cualquier compuesto el pk de antes
de ponerlo con este color si yo quiero
buscar el pp que ve en la wikipedia para
el amoniaco resulta que sí están y me da
como valor 4.5 ok me da como valor 4.75
75 ahora que significa que tenga el p
que ve del amoniaco que es 4.75
bueno pues recuerda que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que decir de granos
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que
tomarme el
pero qué significa el menos logaritmo ok
en base 10 ok de café pero que es justo
lo que nosotros queremos que es la
constante de equilibrio de esta reacción
de esta base así que si queremos
encontrar el valor de café para picar un
poco de álgebra como lo hicimos en el
vídeo pasado entonces lo único que hay
que hacer es despejar a este de aquí
utilizando estos datos es decir que yo
tengo antes en utilizar este color que
menos el logaritmo o que en base 10 de
justo lo que estoy buscando cada vez
esto es igual a 4.75 4.75 y si de aquí
quiero despejar acaben bueno primero voy
a pasar el signo menos y me va a quedar
que el logaritmo ok en base 10 de capem
de capem es exactamente lo mismo que
menos ok 4.75 o dicho de otra manera que
cabe que es justo lo que estamos
buscando va a ser exactamente igual que
el logaritmo en base 10 lo voy a pasar
10 elevado a esta potencia 10 elevado a
la menos 4.75 y ahora para saber la
constante que nosotros buscamos de
equilibrio lo que hace falta es saber
cuánto es esto pero este es un exponente
bastante difícil de hacerlo en nuestra
cabeza así que para eso aunque te parece
si traigo la calculadora déjame sacarla
por aquí ok por aquí tengo mi
calculadora y vamos a ver
por acá cuánto es 10 elevado a la menos
4.75 10 elevado a la am - 4.75 esto es
lo mismo que a 1.778 y esto vamos a
redondear lo a 1.8 ok por 10 a la menos
5 ok eso es importante entonces lo voy a
poner justo a campo en este color café
café vale ok
1.8 ok
10 elevado a la menos 5 de lujo y ahora
podemos utilizar toda esta información
para hacer algo matemático como lo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado muy parecido
a lo que hicimos en el vídeo pasado y
bueno parece que va a ser difícil
descifrar la concentración de hidrógeno
directamente sin embargo no va a ser así
porque es nuestra reacción de equilibrio
solamente tiene hidróxido esta parte de
aquí pero si sabemos la concentración de
hidróxido de esta parte de aquí pues
debemos regresar a la concentración de
hidrógeno recuerdas común bueno pues es
que recuerda que la concentración de
este más la concentración de hidrógeno
tiene que ser igual a 10 elevado a la
menos 14 o dicho de otra manera si
resolvemos el ph más el ph eso va a
tener que ser igual a 14 y de hecho
justo de eso hablamos hace un par de
videos ahora vamos a utilizar toda esta
información para obtener el ph y para
eso pues vamos a ver nuestra constante
que tenemos aquí está de aquí porque
nosotros sabemos que esta constante de
aquí es más déjeme atraparlo ok lo voy a
atrapar
lo voy a copiar y lo voy a pegar ok este
número de aquí tiene que ser exactamente
igual que quien bueno esto tiene que ser
exactamente igual
ponerlo con esto esto tiene que ser
exactamente igual que quien que una
división aunque la división de déjame
ponerlo justo así la división de la
concentración a ok
como denominador tenemos la
concentración de nuestros reactivos de
nuestros reactivos sin embargo recuerda
que el agua es el solvente por lo tanto
nos vamos a incluir y solamente vamos a
incluir al nh 3 la concentración del nh
3 y bueno justo como lo vimos en el
vídeo pasado esto me va a quedar 0.2
molar menos x que x es la cantidad de la
concentración que vamos a obtener aquí
entonces en el denominador vamos a tener
0.2 menos lo que sea que se haya
convertido en el lado derecho
es decir x así que déjame ponerlo con
este color
ok aquí me va a quedar 0.2 menos x
y déjenme ponerlo a escribirlo así que
esta va a ser mi concentración mi
concentración de nh3 ok de lujo que es
mi reactivo y ahora pensemos en los
productos por aquí en esta concentración
de aquí va a ser x déjame ponerlo así x
este de aquí va a ser la concentración
ok de nh4 ok más aquí le voy a poner lo
demás ok
nh 4 más y bueno a esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por la concentración de
este que también sabemos que es x
entonces a esto lo voy a multiplicar por
x que está x de aquí sale de la
concentración ok
h negativo ok justo esto es decir la
concentración de amonio por la
concentración de hidróxido y bueno ya
que tenemos esto simplemente resolvemos
para x ya que tenemos la concentración
de vh que va a ser x bueno pues de una
manera muy sencilla podemos calcular p h
y después podemos descifrar el ph y todo
eso lo haremos cuando multipliquemos
esta parte ampliada
dado si despejamos a x justo como lo
vimos en el vídeo anterior y sólo para
que lo sepas es el mismo paso de
simplificación que hicimos antes la
heurística simplemente es un tipo de
reglas generales que a veces funcionan
me refiero a la simplificación que
hicimos con la x en el vídeo pasado y es
que cuanto te tomas a este de aquí a
este de aquí y ves que es varias veces
menor que este de aquí tiene un orden de
magnitud mucho menor que es de aquí
entonces puedes hacer la simplificación
que hicimos en el vídeo pasado pero
bueno en lugar de tomarnos la
simplificación esta vez lo voy a
resolver utilizando la fórmula
cuadrática y para eso a mí déjame bajar
un poco la pantalla ok
porque ahora vamos a trabajar con esta
parte de aquí ok
fíjate lo primero que vamos a hacer es
multiplicar esta parte por este de aquí
y que me va a quedar bueno pues eso es
lo mismo que 1.8 x 0.2
es lo mismo que 3.6 y le recordó una vez
el punto me va a quedar a ambos de
utilizar este color
punto 36 ok por 10 al menos 5
ok 2 por 18 36 pero recorremos una dos
veces el punto entonces me quedan 0.36
por 10 a la menos 5 ok ya eso le voy a
quitar ok le voy a quitar x porque este
no va a quedar 1.8 ok por dice la menos
5 por 10 elevado en al menos 5 ok x ok y
esto es exactamente igual que x cuadrado
que x por x lo cual es x cuadrado ok ya
tenemos aquí mi ecuación cuadrática o si
quiero pasar todo de un mismo lado de la
ecuación me va a quedar que x cuadrada
ok a este lo voy a pasar del otro lado
con signo positivo va a pasar de este
lago signo positivo o dicho de otra
manera voy a sumar de ambos lados 1.8
por diez el a menos 5x y entonces me
quedaría aquí más 1.8 ok
10 al menos 5 ok x y después a este lo
voy a pasar el otro lado con signo
contrario ha dicho otra manera voy a
restar de ambos lados 0.36 por 10 al
menos 5 - 0.36 ok por ok 10 a la menos 5
y esto
es igual a 0 esto es igual a 0 de lujo y
bueno pues vamos a resolverlo aunque una
vez más recuerda que si quieres hacerlo
podría eliminar justo este término de
aquí y bueno sacar raíz cuadrada esto lo
cual sería muy fácil de hacer pero bueno
no lo voy a hacer y ahora lo que sí voy
a hacer es una ecuación cuadrática y
resolverlo por la fórmula general así
que dejen utilizar otro cuadro este de
aquí va a ser a ok este de aquí es a
este valor de aquí esto que tengo aquí
va a ser el valor debe ok y esto que
tengo aquí a esto todo esto es
ok por lo tanto x
punto lo que queremos averiguar x o la
concentración de hidróxido que es justo
lo que queremos averiguar va a ser
exactamente igual que menos be ok pero
ves esto entonces me queda menos 1.8 ok
por 10 elevado a la menos 5 ok menos ve
más menos pero recuerda que solamente me
voy a tomar el signo positivo porque si
me lo tomo con signo negativo bueno me
quedaría una concentración negativa lo
cual no tiene lógica entonces solamente
me voy a tomar a esto con signo positivo
más la raíz cuadrada déjame ponerlo así
para que no se vea mucho mejor
ok la raíz cuadrada de quien bueno debe
cuadrada es decir de 1.8 politizar menos
5 al cuadrado y bueno cuánto es eso a mí
déjame sacar para eso en mi calculadora
ok y vamos a ver cuánto es 1.8 1.8
elevado al cuadrado
ok esto es lo mismo que tres puntos 24
ok vamos a ponerlo aquí
punto 24 ok por 10 elevado a la menos 5
esto elevado al cuadrado bueno pues es
10 elevado a la menos 10 a la menos días
esto se multiplica por dos ya esto hay
que quitarle menos cuatro veces menos
cuatro veces hacen pero vale uno
entonces se queda igual y después éste
es negativo así que no te dar positivo
ok y 4 por a 0.36 por 10 al menos 5
vamos a hacer eso de nuevo con nuestra
calculadora ok si yo lo que quiero es
multiplicar 4 ok por un 0.36
por punto 36 o esperar a esto lo voy a
quitar no va a quedar 36 y esto es lo
mismo que 144 claro eso lo pude haber
hecho hasta mental 1.44 así que permitan
este y voy a poner a 1.44 más 1.44 por
10 elevado a la a menos 5 por 10 elevado
a la menos 5 y bueno claro todo esto hay
que dividirlo todo esto hay que
dividirlo entre dos veces am pero a vale
1 entonces solamente lo voy a dividir
entre 2 ok y ahora vamos a resolver esto
pero déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla
para seguir trabajando justo esta
información ok y si ahora de nuevo
sacamos por acá a mi calculadora para
terminar de hacer este ejercicio que me
va a quedar ok de que nos puede dar por
aquí tengo tres puntos 24 por 10 a la
menos días antes de no ponerlo con
paréntesis 3.24 ok
antes el primero si diez elevado elevado
al menos diez ok esto a esto le voy a
sumar 1.44 prótesis de 15 a esto debe
sumar 1.44 ok esto por 10 por ander no
ponerlo con paréntesis así que aquí le
voy a agregar un paréntesis an por 10
elevado elevado al menos 5 ok a eso me
va a dar bueno esta cantidad de aquí ya
esto hay que sacar la raíz cuadrada así
que saquemos de la raíz cuadrada de una
vez y es lo mismo que esta cantidad de
aquí ok y bueno a esta cantidad de aquí
que es 0.003 79 a 53 ok terminó con él
aquí entonces me va a quedar que x
déjame poner con este mismo color x va a
ser exactamente igual que anne y vamos a
cambiar el color menos 1.8 ok
por 10 elevado a la menos cinco más 0.1
003 ok 7 9 795 ok todo esto han dividido
todo esto a su vez dividido entre 2 ok
pues vamos a ver cuánto vale x y de
nuevo voy a traer para acá a mi
calculadora ok ya tengo justo aquí y
ahora déjame ponerla por aquí porque a
esta cantidad le voy a quitar ok déjame
ponerlo así porque a las respuestas le
voy a quitar a 1.8 1.8 por 10 elevado a
la menos 5 ok es lo mismo que esta
cantidad ya esto lo voy a dividir entre
2 ok y eso es lo mismo que esto esta es
mi respuesta 0.001 88
x x
que es justo lo que nosotros buscamos x
va a ser exactamente igual que vamos a
cambiar de color 0.00 1888 y bueno sería
muy bueno recordar a aquí equivalía x y
si recuerdas justo aquí lo pusimos x era
la concentración de h hoy la
concentración de amonio pero nos
interesa el h así que déjenme bajar la
pantalla ok y vamos a poner que x ok es
exactamente igual a déjame ponerlo con
este valor es exactamente igual que la
concentración que buscábamos de oh
ok este con signo menos y está del lujo
porque ya tenemos la concentración de h
y ahora si nosotros queremos saber cuál
es mi p o h bueno pues solamente tenemos
que tomar el menos logaritmo de este
número así que antes de bajar un poco en
la pantalla ok
y vamos a calcular cuánto vale
justo con este color ok
o h ok en este caso va a ser exactamente
igual que el menos logaritmo en base 10
de esto el menos logaritmo en base 10 de
0.00 18 org
ok 8 y esto en cuanto más ampliamente
una vez trae por acá y calculadora de
nuevo ok y vamos a ver cuál es el
logaritmo de esto que tenemos aquí ok
esto es exactamente lo mismo que en
menos dos puntos 72 pero yo lo quiero
negativo aunque entonces lo negativo de
esto es dos puntos 72 ok de jamón por lo
que esto va a ser exactamente igual que
en 2.72 y es justo lo que yo quería el p
h porque ya teniendo el veo h
va a ser muy fácil calcular el p h y de
hecho si queremos saber cuál es el ph y
recordando que es la concentración de
iones de hidrógeno sólo recuerda que
cuando estás en una solución acuosa a 25
grados celsius
w antes de ponerlo así el p ok k w a 25
grados celsius del agua este es
exactamente igual que el p
antes de ponerlo con este color que el p
o h
ok más el ph que voy a poner con este
color más el p h ok y entonces antes de
bajar un poco la pantalla porque ya
estamos a punto de acabar
si nosotros sabemos que esto es cierto
para el agua a 25 grados celsius y bueno
recuerda que sabemos eso porque este de
aquí es 14 am verme ponerlo con este
color este de aquí es 14 porque recuerda
que cuando nosotros tenemos agua más la
concentración molares del 10 elevado a
la menos 14 y bueno realmente no quiero
tocar mucho eso para no confundir t pero
si ese es 10 elevado a la menos 14 pk w
es 14 eso cuando nosotros pensamos en la
constante de equilibrio para la
disociación del agua pero el ph y el ph
del agua neutra es 7
ahora no tenemos siete aquí tenemos dos
puntos 72 lo que quiere decir que el ph
es bajo y si el ph es bajo ok entonces
este va a subir en fin no quiero
confundirte el mejor vamos a hacerlo con
un poco de álgebra aquí tengo 2.72
antequera empujando aquí dos puntos 72 y
nosotros queremos averiguar cuánto vale
el ph más p h ok y entonces si nosotros
sabemos el ph a el ph va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que han dejado con
este color
14 - 2 puntos 72 am habrá que averiguar
cuántos esto vamos a verlo con nuestra
calculadora ok a esta cantidad de aquí
la voy a convertir en negativa ok
y después le voy a sumar 14 ok
esto va a ser lo mismo que 11.27
lo voy a redondear en 11.3 ok entonces
el ph que nosotros buscábamos el p h que
nosotros estamos buscando es 11.3 es
justo es lo que nosotros estábamos
buscando este ph y está de lujo porque
eso tiene bastante sentido con lo que
dijimos que el amoniaco
justo por acá regresemos un poco todos
los que hicimos el amoniaco este de aquí
es antes de ponerlo con este color es
una base débil recuerdas es una base
débil así que es básico lo que quiere
decir que su ph and su ph debe de ser
más grande que 7 pero como es una base
débil no es tan grande como 14 y dejen
regresar un poco la pantalla para ver
nuestros resultados ok
nosotros tenemos justo por aquí de lujo
que tenemos un ph de 11.3 esto cuando
hablamos de amoniaco ok nh3 y tenemos
cero
punto 2 molar de amoniaco en fin como
sea este fue un problema bastante
matemático de hecho tiene más
matemáticas que química pero espero que
te haya aclarado algunas cosas